[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
publique la relativité restreinte
imaginons un vaisseau spatial ainsi qu
une planète isolée au fin fond de
l'univers
on va supposer que le vaisseau est en
mouvement par rapport à la planète selon
une direction fixe et une vitesse
constante
une première propriété fondamentale de
l'univers et que dans cette situation il
est strictement impossible de déterminer
si c'est le vaisseau qui se déplace et
la planète qui reste immobile ou au
contraire si le vaisseau est immobile et
que c'est la planète qui se déplace dans
l'autre sens
c'est ce qu'on appelle le principe de
relativité
quel que soit le point de vue que l'on
adopte du moment que le mouvement se
fait en ligne droite à vitesse constante
il est tout autant valide de considérer
que c'est soit le vaisseau soit la
planète qui se déplace imaginons
maintenant un passager du vaisseau qui
va décider de lancer une balle vers
l'avant pour lui la balle se déplace
vers l'avant avec une certaine vitesse
cette vitesse correspond tout simplement
à l'impulsion qu'il lui a donné
mais si on observe la même situation
depuis la planète
la balle semble se déplacer plus
rapidement car à sa vitesse d'impulsion
s'ajoute également la vitesse du
vaisseau lui-même chose étrange si l'on
essaye maintenant de faire la même
expérience avec de la lumière cette fois
ci en utilisant par exemple lampe torche
on observe que quel que soit le point de
vue adopté la vitesse de la lumière est
la même qu'on la regarde
immobile ou en se déplaçant qu'on l'a
propulsé depuis un point fixe ou un
point en mouvement on verra toujours la
lumière se déplacer avec exactement la
même vitesse on dit que cette vitesse de
la lumière est invariante la vitesse de
la lumière est une constante universelle
fondamental à la base de la structure
même de l'univers dans notre quotidien
la vitesse de la lumière est bien trop
élevé pour qu'on puisse remarquer un
quelconque effet de ce principe en
seulement l'espace d'un clignement
d'oeil un rayon lumineux aura parcouru
l'équivalent de trois allers retours
paris new york
toutefois cette propriété subtil de la
lumière va entraîner des changements
drastiques sur notre façon de voir le
monde en relativité restreinte
une des idées les plus fondamentales et
que deux événements peuvent se produire
en même temps pour une personne mais à
des moments différents
pour quelqu'un d'autre pour comprendre
imaginons la situation suivante le
passager qui se trouve au milieu du
vaisseau se muni de deux lampes torches
une qu'il va orienter vers l'arrière et
l'autre vers l'avant son rôle va être
allumé les deux lampes torches
exactement en même temps il va ensuite
regardez à quel moment arrive les deux
rayons lumineux aux extrémités du
vaisseau il commence par allumer les
deux lampes torches
au même moment étant donné que selon son
point de vue le vaisseau reste immobile
les rayons lumineux vont se propager de
la même façon des deux côtés ils vont
ainsi atteindre les deux extrémités du
vaisseau au même moment pour le passager
les deux événements sont donc simultané
les rayons lumineux ont atteint les deux
extrémités du vaisseau en même temps
mais regardons maintenant cette même
situation telle qu'elle est perçue par
un observateur à la surface de la
planète
on a vu précédemment que la vitesse de
la lumière est invariante par conséquent
au moment où les deux lampes torches
s'allume leur lumière va se propager à
la même vitesse des deux côtés mais
pendant ce temps le vaisseau se déplace
vers l'avant ainsi le rayon lumineux qui
est envoyé vers la gauche va atteindre
l'arrière du vaisseau avant que le rayon
lumineux de droite la teigne l'avant
selon ce point de vue les deux
événements ne sont donc plus simultané
les rayons lumineux n'atteignent pas les
extrémités du vaisseau au même moment
pour expliquer ce paradoxe
il va nous falloir bouleverser notre
compréhension intuitive de ce qu'est le
temps dans la situation précédente
si le rayon lumineux de gauche atteint
le bord du vaisseau avant le rayon
lumineux de droite
c'est en réalité parce que l'arrière du
vaisseau et légèrement dans le futur par
rapport à l'avant du vaisseau qui est
légèrement dans le passé grossièrement
lorsqu'il est par exemple midi au milieu
du vaisseau il est déjà 13 heures à
l'arrière du vaisseau mais il n'est
encore que 11 heures à l'avant du
vaisseau depuis de passagers à
l'intérieur les horloges sont pourtant
parfaitement synchronisé pour lui il est
tout aussi bien midi à l'avant qu'à
l'arrière du vaisseau c'est le fait de
l'observer depuis un point en mouvement
qui va désynchronisée l'arrière et
l'avant du vaisseau
de manière plus générale lorsqu'un objet
se déplace à très grande vitesse par
rapport à nous on observe que l'avant de
l'objet est en retard dans le temps par
rapport à l'arrière si l'on plaçait par
exemple deux personnes du même âge aux
extrémités du vaisseau ou n'observerait
depuis la planète que la personne à
l'avant du vaisseau est légèrement plus
jeune et la personne à l'arrière
légèrement plus âgés une conséquence
directe de ce phénomène est ce qu'on
appelle la contraction des longueurs
comme on l'a vu précédemment
lorsqu'il est observée depuis la planète
l'arrière du vaisseau et légèrement dans
le futur par rapport à l'avant mais
comme le vaisseau se déplace au cours du
temps si l'arrière du vaisseau et dans
le futur
il est également légèrement en avance
par rapport à son mouvement de même
l'avant est légèrement en retrait par
rapport aux mouvements du vaisseau la
longueur globale du vaisseau se voit
donc contracté dans le sens de sa
vitesse à des vitesses d'ordinaire cette
contraction est minime quasiment
indétectables par exemple une voiture se
déplaçant à 130 kilomètres par heure ne
sera contracté que d'environ la largeur
d'un noyau d'atome mais plus on se
rapproche de la vitesse de la lumière
plus ce phénomène de contraction devient
important si notre vaisseau pouvait se
déplacer à 85 % de la vitesse de la
lumière
sa longueur serait contracté de moitié
et à 99,5 % de la vitesse de la lumière
sa longueur observés ne serait plus
qu'un dixième de sa longueur original
dans cette situation vue depuis la
planète le vaisseau nous semble
terriblement contracter mais du point de
vue du passage et qui se trouve à
l'intérieur
ce n'est pas le vaisseau qui est
contractée mais la planète car selon son
point de vue c'est la planète qui se
déplace et non le vaisseau
[Musique]
enfin une troisième conséquence directe
de l'invariance de la vitesse de la
lumière est ce qu'on appelle la
dilatation des durées pour comprendre
imaginons l'expérience suivante le
passager à l'intérieur du vaisseau se
munit à nouveau d'une lampe torche qu'il
va cette fois ci dirigée vers le haut un
instant donné il va allumer la lampe
torche et observer le temps que met le
rayon lumineux pour atteindre le plafond
du vaisseau encore une fois le problème
va changer si l'on décident d'observer
la même situation
et depuis la planète pour l'observateur
qui se trouve sur la planète
le vaisseau et le passager qu'il
contient sont en mouvement
par conséquent le faisceau lumineux va
non seulement devoir parcourir la
hauteur jusqu'au plafond
mais il va également devoir se déplacer
vers la droite en suivant le mouvement
du vaisseau d'après ce point de vue le
rayon lumineux doit donc parcourir une
distance plus grande et par conséquent
tout comme il faut plus de temps pour
traverser une route en diagonale que
dans le sens de la largeur
il va falloir à la lumière plus de temps
pour atteindre le plafond du vaisseau
pour cet observateur qui regarde la
situation depuis la planète
le rayon lumineux a donc mis davantage
de temps pour atteindre le haut du
vaisseau en général cet observateur va
voir l'intérieur du vaisseau évolué au
ralenti si le passager du vaisseau
décidé par exemple de lui montrer une
horloge on observerait depuis la planète
que cette horloge s'écoule au ralenti
plus généralement lorsqu'un objet se
déplace très rapidement par rapport à
nous on verra son arrière et son avant
désynchronisée sa longueur contracter et
on le verra évoluer au ralenti pour
résumer tous ces phénomènes
on va s'intéresser au cas concrets des
murs dans la haute atmosphère
il arrive régulièrement que pénètre des
particules cosmiques
ces particules cosmiques très
énergétiques vont progressivement se
désintégrer jusqu'à engendrer des
particules élémentaires qu'on appelle
des millions dans une situation normale
s'est mué en ont une durée de vie
extrêmement courte ils disparaissent au
bout de quelques micro secondes
seulement
mais pourtant lorsqu'on essaye de les
détecter depuis la surface de la terre
on se rend compte qu'un grand nombre de
semyon parvient tout de même à atteindre
le sol
cette situation à première vue paradoxal
va pouvoir s'expliquer grâce au
phénomène qu'on a vu précédemment
en effet les millions qui chute vers le
sol peuvent atteindre des vitesses
vertigineuses
près de 99 points 5 % de la vitesse de
la lumière
on va donc devoir s'intéresser au
phénomène de contraction des longueurs
et de dilatation des durées d'une part
commençons par nous placer du point de
vue d'un mur pour le million c'est la
terre et en particulier l'atmosphère qui
se déplace très rapidement dans sa
direction
par le phénomène de contraction des
longueurs le mieux on va donc voir une
atmosphère contractée beaucoup plus fine
et par conséquent il va pouvoir la
traverser entièrement avant d'avoir eu
le temps de disparaître
[Musique]
d'autre part si l'on se place du point
de vue d'un observateur sur terre ce
sont les muons qui se déplace avec une
très grande vitesse par le phénomène de
dilatation des durées on va donc voir
les murs ont évolué au ralenti et par
conséquent leur durée de vie va nous
sembler très allongé encore une fois les
muons vont avoir le temps d'atteindre le
sol
bien avant de ne s'être désintégré pour
conclure le simple fait que la vitesse
de la lumière soit invariante entraînent
de très lourdes conséquences sur notre
façon de voir le monde
lorsqu'un objet se déplacent par rapport
à nous en ligne droite avec une très
grande vitesse
on le voit évoluer au ralenti tandis
qu'il nous semble contractée dans le
sens du mouvement
cette façon de comprendre la relativité
du temps et de l'espace en fonction du
mouvement des objets est ce qu'on
appelle la relativité restreinte elle
nous enseigne que le temps et l'espace
ne sont pas des notions absolue que deux
observateurs vont potentiellement les
percevoir de façon différente
elle entraîne également un grand nombre
d'autres conséquences comme le fait
qu'il soit absolument impossible de
dépasser la vitesse de la lumière car ne
serait ce que pour atteindre cette
vitesse il faudrait disposer d'une
quantité infinie d'énergie mais cette
forme de relativité et d'appeler
restreinte car elle ne s'applique que
dans des cas très simple pour des
mouvements qui ne se font qu'en ligne
droite et à vitesse constante
elle n'est pas en mesure de décrire
d'autres types de mouvements par exemple
des changements de direction des
accélérations des ralentissements ou
encore des rotations
pour ce faire il va être nécessaire de
s'intéresser à une théorie beaucoup plus
complète qui permet entre autres
d'expliquer l'attraction
gravitationnelle à partir d'une
géométrie des formes et de l'espace et
du temps
c'est ce qu'on appelle la relativité
générale
[Musique]